[Music]
these little creatures can be
complicated
they're cute but mischievous it's my
pizza they may have earned a bad rap
from their Antics but their
problem-solving skills Inspire
scientific studies
interactions with them are unpredictable
and as our cities spread into their
homes that's only increasing so let's
take a closer look at raccoons
I think I have one of the best jobs in
the world I am
I in particular animal cognition and
animal behavior this is Dr Sarah Benson
Amron and she works with some pretty
great office mates I find it a really
fun challenge to try to put myself into
the minds of these animals and come up
with a task that I think is going to be
fair and actually get at the cognitive
ability that I'm trying to assess every
time we test the raccoon it just ends up
leading to 20 more questions you could
study them for a lifetime and never get
bored
smart adaptable and carrying a famous
resemblance around the eyes
Native American folklore tells of a
muddy brawl with a coyote that caused
the face mask and their know-it-all
Antics from being The Reincarnation of a
disobedient human
whether past or present they leave an
impression
raccoons definitely have a reputation
for being mischievous and they're very
good at doing things that we can find
pretty frustrating Light breaking into
trash cans or getting into your house
but to be fair
we're kind of breaking into there
we're taking over more natural land and
more Wildlife are getting pushed into
human-dominated Landscapes and we're
talking a lot of Landscapes like 24
million Acres of natural space lost to
Urban expansion the
size of Nine Grand Canyons
you have a lot of wildlife that is
declining and even disappearing from
some areas
but then you also have these other
Wildlife species that are able to
successfully live in cities and
sometimes even use human provided
resources
which brings us back to our crafty
neighbors raccoons are really Adept at
changing their behavior but they're not
avoiding people as much as they're
taking advantage of a lot of the
resources despite how hard we try to
keep them away we put out fences we put
bungee cords on our trash cans so we're
basically presenting Urban Wildlife with
increasingly difficult challenges and
they're solving those challenges which
raises the question just how smart are
these animals
we've given them different cognitive
tasks to specifically assess this
ability of theirs to change their
behavior rapidly one test studies
cognitive flexibility with a three-part
puzzle another looks at reversal
learning by pressing buttons
but it's a fable from a couple thousand
years ago that inspires the third
today's Aesop's Fable Paradigm is taken
from the Aesop stable the crow in the
picture there's a Thirsty Crow and it
finds a pitcher of water there's only a
little bit of water in that picture and
the crow can't reach it so this Crow
drops don't into the pitcher which
raises the water level now the crow can
get a drink and in real life birds like
Rooks and crows can actually solve this
problem as well as another animal you
might recognize
we found some really interesting
differences between what we see with
raccoons and what they see in other
studies unlike the corvids they don't
just take one stone drop it in get the
reward and finish they actually take all
the stones dump them all in and just are
playing with this thing constantly so
they get the reward but then they just
keep playing with it or they take the
stones and they go hide them in their
bedding so that they can play with them
later
once the raccoons learned this you can
test them to see really how much they
understand about the problem for example
you can give them a floating ball versus
a sinking ball if they understand they
should choose the sinking ball because
the floating ball won't actually help
them to get their reward they actually
didn't show a preference for the sinking
ball what they've figured out is that
they could actually make the floating
ball work they learn to push it up and
down in the water to bounce it and that
would spray marshmallow bits up the side
of the tube so they could get the reward
so we're seeing that they're really
creative problem solvers
so for those skilled problem solvers
what can we learn from their brains
raccoons who can solve a problem in
multiple ways have more cells in their
hippocampus and the hippocampus is
thought to be this really important
brain region for cognition specifically
memory and learning interestingly it's
actually that they have more
non-neuronal cells so things like glia
which is helpful considering a higher
ratio of glia to neurons could increase
neuroplasticity which is your ability to
flexibly switch your behavior Albert
Einstein notably had a really high Julia
Turner on ratio and humans actually have
a higher glia tenora ratio than other
primates
so we're learning that raccoon brain
power plays a role in their cognitive
flexibility
but there's another physical feature
that contributes to their craftiness
raccoons are very famous for their
dexterous for Paws so they have these
five long fingers like primates just
without opposable thumbs hey instead
they can use sort of both Four Paws
together to lift and then manipulate
objects and while this manipulation
skill is Handy
all right all right it's not their only
feature their sense of touch is
incredibly sensitive evolutionarily
raccoons were trying to find food in
really murky water or in the dirt
underneath the water and so they're
digging around but they're not able to
see what they're doing and so they're
really heavily relying on this tactile
ability which explains another endearing
trait they've held onto
people think oh when raccoon to put
something in water they're washing it
but actually when they put something in
water their tactile senses heightened to
feel things even more finely
as Urban environments are expanding that
can have a lot of really dramatic
consequences for wildlife designing
mitigation strategies for human Wildlife
conflict will be really critical
for some cities ecological restoration
has already shown promising results by
boosting biodiversity reducing city
pollution and connecting people with
nature there's this effect that when
people connect to Nature in their
backyards then they connect to Nature
even more globally they're more likely
to be involved in conservation efforts
around the world and so that's something
that we're really excited about to help
people to get involved in community
science projects and to really get
people excited about what's happening in
their city in their backyard with
wildlife
[Music]
thank you